been part of the International Community
and behaving like it is the way you
police the numbers but the idea that
there's going to be a million people
coming when we already take only a
quarter of what Germany takes only seven
percent of all of the eu's
um refugees is a reminder that this is a
problem but it's not the kind of
Emergency the United Kingdom government
is making out that it is and so my
accusation really is the government
knows this and rather than being mature
about the problem and acknowledging that
is a difficult problem with tough
solutions that involve more than one
solution is going for something
simplistic that won't work and threatens
Britain's status around the world and is
also in human